hey guys welcome back to Branham vide
we're back on apex legends again and
today we have some more interesting news
to talk about a release date for one of
the leaked characters and they're also a
list of all the possible upcoming
characters that were leaked and what
like I said one of those characters
within that list is gonna be releasing
sometime soon so let's get started with
today's video as well as like the VP do
enjoy a subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of Apex legends that
being balanced changes new events new
characters new legends you want to stay
up to date with everything happening in
the world of apex legends they subscribe
to the channel and with that let's get
started with today's video first up
we're gonna go over the huge list of the
characters now a bunch of data monitors
have been going into the game and
looking at all this type of stuff cuz
apparently it's pretty easy to do this I
guess I don't know if your dad a miner I
guess it's pretty easy but the names of
ten characters or more than ten
characters have been named in these are
some of the names including Krypto
husaria Jericho nomads octane a prophet
rampart Rosie scunner and Watson these
were originally found after a series of
audio files were found and sing them pop
up again in this leak makes it more
likely that the rest of the apex legends
cast will most likely be legitimate so
this is pretty nice to see it also says
here with the battle past first coming
as the star is the early as next month
with a new game update planned next week
it's most likely new details about these
legends and characters are just around
the corner and that's pretty true I'm
actually very excited to hear what these
characters are gonna be but let's go
over to the other tab that they have on
gaming in Telkom and as always I will
leave the links for both of these in the
description if you do want to look at
the stuff for yourself and on this one
it says this gaming intel has found
evidence of a potential release date for
the newer for the first new apex legend
character octane and it's closer than
you might expect when apex legends
released the road map they show the stat
we'd be getting at least one new legend
in each of their four seasons over the
course of 2019 other than that they gave
no information about what the legend
characters would be or who they would be
in health it would work but while
digging the files that happen to find a
folder called post-launch playlists
which may have accidentally let slip
during the reveal and this may actually
show the release date for the new apex
legends character octane now the files
do claim that on week 8 a new playlist
will be added to the game something
about a nacht 8 in preview this could be
the news tab coming up when you come
into the game or some in-game event
talking about octane coming to the game
or something like that but week 8
actually if you talk about the release
date of apex is gonna be somewhere
between
March 25th and April 1st so it's gonna
be roughly around this time if the week
8 is correct is when he should be
releasing now actually octane is one of
the most talked-about characters in
terms of unreleased content and because
of these leaks and according to these
leaks from gaming in Telecom they do
suggest that octane is going to contain
a type of stem pack and his abilities
and an item where you would be getting
health regeneration or reload speed and
a movement speed boost to a pull to a
player like in previous titanfall games
there's also been leaks about an undo
item coming to the game known as jump
pads now this might actually not be with
the character or this could be some type
of other type of things love very
similar to the balloons within Kings
Canyon but my thoughts is that it could
also be his type of ultimate or instead
of using a balloon you can plop this
down wherever you want to use and it's
just like a balloon except it's a launch
pad and it's this ultimate that could
totally be a thing I could definitely
see that happening but let me know your
thoughts on that hey guys it's gonna be
the end of the vid say hopefully you
guys did enjoy it like the video if you
did I'll leave the links to everything I
talked about in the description from
gaming intel.com
as I stink you gave me Intel for all the
beautiful news you guys been super
helpful we're giving me content to work
with and also sharing with the community
on what's been happening within the game
hey guys let me know your thoughts on
what you think octane is gonna look like
if these abilities seem viable I'm one
of what your thoughts on all the apex
Legends characters being leaked octane
Watson Rosie all that type of [ __ ] let
me know guys as opinions on that I mean
that like to be if you do enjoy
subscriber for new I covered the
informational side of apex legends that
being the balance changes the updates
the new legends anything that happens to
do with apex legends I will be covering
so if you want to stay up to date with
everything happening in the world of
apex legends and never miss out an
update that would stay subscribe to the
channel is that my two most recent
videos would be on-screen if you guys do
want to check that out with that guys
hope I have a greatest today and thank
you for watching the video and peace out
[Music]